[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight things are moving fast but think
back if you still can to ten years ten
years ago what were democrats saying
about abortion at that time a decade ago
well they said they believed in Roe vs.
Wade
they said that abortion was never
preferable but it ought to be legal for
the first trimester of pregnancy they
were not they often told us pro-abortion
they were pro-choice and a lot of voters
by the way agreed with them you might
not like it but according to the polls
that was a mainstream position but
that's not where Democratic leaders are
today the party's new position is the
more abortion the better abortion must
be available for any reason at all up
until the moment of birth as an op-ed in
The New York Times this morning put it
quote pregnancy kills abortion save
lives in other words it's better to
abort a pregnancy than to bring it to
term that's their view how many voters
agree with that almost none most people
will find it disgusting just as most
people according to polls don't think
taxpayers ought to be forced to pay for
abortion the Democrats running for
president don't care what the polls say
therefore it will you commit to
abolishing the Hyde Amendment which
hurts women
yes sir by the way make sure you
remember I got a near-perfect voting
record my entire career right now this
has to be okay stay I will work to
overturn the Hyde Amendment which makes
it impossible for low-income women to
get access to reproductive care
including abortion services the Hyde
Amendment for more than 40 years the
Hyde Amendment has protected people of
faith from being forced to pay for what
they think is killing certainly peabody
judge would understand that as a man of
god but a judge has spent the last few
months accentuating his personal
holiness just the other day he told us
that the lord strongly prefers him to
mike pence so where does st. Pete of
South Bend on the question of abortion
well he's strongly for it his position
is that any restriction at all for any
reason at all is unacceptable
most Americans believe that it should be
up to the woman to make that choice so
by pursuing a radical extreme agenda on
these social issues I think ins are
doing the same thing that they've done
when they've resisted a popular agenda
on things like living wages or
healthcare it's just one more example of
the extremism of the moderate Republican
Party so you want fewer abortions
according to holy man Pete Buddha judge
that makes you crazy and possibly
dangerous certainly an extremist notice
that Buddha judge has no problem at all
with Senator mazie Hirono of Hawaii
just yesterday Hirono ghoulishly bragged
about brainwashing middle schoolers to
support abortion
[Music]
government should be telling us whether
when and if we want to have babies
neither one of them raise your
[Applause]
government should be telling girls and
women when and if we're going to have
babies imagine saying something like
that to someone else's kids Senator Cory
Booker can easily imagine it like mazie
Hirono Booker has no children of his own
but he is fervently committed to
abortion so committed to it that if
elected Cory Booker has promised to
create something called the White House
Office of reproductive freedom the only
point of the office would be to ensure
that we have enough abortions in this
country Cory book Cory Booker believes
that abortions are a vital strategic
resource like oil or uranium it would be
interesting to know why Cory Booker
believes that like most of the
Democratic candidates he refuses to come
on this show so we can't ask him
directly but we'd love to know what he
makes for example of the abortion rate
in black America african-american women
are five times as likely to get
abortions as white women in the United
States
what does Cory Booker think of that is
it something to celebrate should we be
fighting to get the abortion rate even
higher what about sex selective
abortions they're common are they
morally okay would it be all right to
abort a pregnancy if you thought the
child was gonna grow up to be gay or
short or prematurely bald thanks to
genetic testing those may soon be real
questions is there any abortion under
any circumstances that's ever bad or
even a little bad
or are they all morally neutral no
matter what the cause or stage of
pregnancy those are the most basic
questions about abortion nobody on the
other channel ever asks them that's a
shame the answers would be fascinating